the reaction to what happened in Israel
has showed us a disturbing window into
how
widespread um Jew hatred and evil is
it's been it's been a massive massive
wakeup call for some people I mean it
college students Elites that are
cheering it on that are saying it's
terrific what happened um and The
Butchery the savagery and I mean I it's
not hard to understand how the Holocaust
happened and Charlie can that's you a
question bro like the the the squad cuz
you we saw reports somebody from I think
I could I I'm guessing it was Fox they
were going up to what's her name uh not
Elan Omar who's the other one rash and
they're just asking her p and if it's
okay we'll show it they're just asking
her are you cool with children getting
beheaded I get that you're from
Palestine and I understand that you have
the flag question she was born in
America she's born in America but that's
and some of them were beheaded right in
front of their parents and then their
parents were killed after the parents
had to watch their babies beheaded so
that's what uh and then she has a
Palestinian flag outside of her office
so Hillary's asking her about do you
condone what's happening
watch terrorist have cut off babies
heads and burn children alive do you
support Israel's rights to defend
themselves against morality her handlers
in front you can't comment about Hamas
terrorist chopping off baby heads do you
condone what Kamas has done chopping off
baby's Heads Burning children alive
raping women in the street look at that
she doesn't give a of course she
she doesn't care why why would she she
doesn't care she follows her told her to
the elevator I would have gone in with
her being chopped off
look look look what is he going to do
like who is this guy get out of here bro
Congressman why do you have a
Palestinian flag outside your office if
you do not condone what Kamas terce has
done to Israel yeah because think about
this uh because that two things can
exist two things can exist in the same
time right guys you can you can denounce
the Mur what Hamas is doing to the
innocent lives and at the same time
still say my heart goes out to the
Palestinians and the children that are
going to be affected yes I mean it's
just it's a typical political answer
terrible what happened please leave me
alone you know let let let's let tension
simmer but she's silent you know why her
constituency supports this yep and we
don't have time to get into that Patrick
but it's it it has been a big
disappointment
how many American Muslims have have been
vocal in support of this it's been a
massive massive disappointment one thing
to consider is look as a Jew you know I
empathize with the people of Gaza I do
like if you're dealing in this sort of
Quasi open air prison style system with
on lockdown I get it why would you be
angry but you also have to look in the
mirror you've elected Hamas to be over
50% of your government that is Isis that
is Hezbollah that is Al Qaeda that's who
you've elected now for the other half
that did not elect them I empathize with
you but here's the next question you
talked about the Allies or the peace
treaties that Israel has whether it's
Jordan whether it's Egypt what they're
working on they have to be very careful
the country right next to Gaza is what
Egypt Egypt so let's focus on Egypt for
a second they don't want them okay why
won't Egypt open up their borders the
Sinai Peninsula is right there massive
desert why won't they open borders to
help their fellow brother brother Muslim
Brotherhood why won't they do that cuz
they know once they once they open those
borders it's not just innocent civilians
coming through it is Hamas militant
Islamic terrorist everyone in the
regionu that will be showing up to Egypt
so everyone wants to place blame on
Israel and I get it let me but let's
talk about your friends Egypt right
there being like no no nothing to see
here no what why not egyp what Netanyahu
should do if if we had an American
president which we don't we have a
traitor in the opal office is the next
flight should be to the Middle East and
say BB we give you four billion a year
don't invade yet you can do your Rockets
or whatever and you have you bring in
the King Abdullah from Jordan you bring
in whoever's is Al still running Egypt I
can't keep track you bring in anyone
who's sympathetic and you have a joint
press conference or you first a meeting
with BB and
say Here's here's what we're going to do
we're going to go in and kill Hamas okay
and you let the Arab leaders talk deep
the Arab leaders actually hate Hamas
like they really do they know it's
aligned with Iran you got to get these
guys in a room you got to have some sort
of uh an agreement some sort of because
here the problem is again overreaction
it's just going to take one of these
actors all it takes is for Egypt to say
our our neutrality is gone wof man that
that would be a disaster it would be a
disaster for the world but that's where
American leadership can come in right
Trump would do that immediately he did
the Abraham Accords Joe Biden has
everyone at War Donald Trump had peace
with Israel Saudi Arabia the UAE he had
flights going from the UAE to Israel
still does because of what Donald Trump
did and Joe Biden has babies being
butchered in
Israel